Florida has fired the scientists who created
their coronavirus dashboard that tracks most
states have something like this.
It tracks daily cases and deaths and other
data.
And it is alleged that she has been fired
because she was refusing to manipulate or
I would call it falsified data for political
reasons to make reopening seem like a more
reasonable thing to do.
Now, this scientist's name is Rebecca Jones.
She put together these dashboards so that
you could go and see in real time where are
the outbreaks, where the cases and deaths.
She wasn't paid for this additional work that
she did.
She did it over a two month period.
And it is claimed that she was told to censor
or manipulate some data and she refused to
do it.
She was told to manually change some data
to help build the case that reopening makes
sense.
And she refused to do it, as she says, and
she has now been fired.
Now, the interesting thing about this coming
out of Florida is that I guess it was almost
two weeks ago, I think I was on the not the
last Friday show, but the previous one or
maybe the one before that time is all blending
together.
We had reports from a few weeks ago that Florida
was already being accused of being dishonest
about their deaths and they were shielding
cause of death from these reporting agencies.
This, if true, is North Korea style propaganda.
Too many deaths and cases to reopen just make
up different numbers.
No problem whatsoever.
And again, I think it's important to underscore
that a lot of the headlines say that she was
refusing to manipulate data.
She was refusing to falsify data, selectively
releasing data or changes or manipulation.
This is falsification.
It would be a form of fraud or straight up
lies.
They are doing what Trump and Republicans
have been accusing China of doing.
have been said.
You know, maybe the death tolls are being
overstated.
Well, it looks like they are being accused
of doing the exact thing, although in the
opposite direction, to make this seem less
bad than it actually is.
Now, of course, there are always details that
are late coming in.
What she straight up fired or forced to resign?
It's not clear.
She's not communicating very much.
Rebecca Jones is with with reporters over
the last 12 to 16 hours.
What exactly was she asked to change?
We're not really sure yet.
What was observed was that over the last couple
weeks, the demographic info about who is getting
infected and dying has been more difficult
to access.
As one example, reporters have been having
more and more trouble finding out how many
cases and deaths are coming from Long-Term
Care in nursing home type facilities and prisons,
which are big hotspots for outbreaks of coronavirus.
At one point, as I told you, the Florida state
government prevented stopped medical examiners
from releasing death totals and also cause
of death.
And both of those things were being done there
for for for many, many years.
That was standard operating practice.
We reported on that already.
And as usual, we still don't have transparency
in terms of the full scope of what they're
hiding or potentially falsifying.
We do need to get more of the story from Rebecca
Jones.
She hopefully will be more communicative with
reporters in the upcoming period of time.
Now, in terms of the numbers that Florida
has been releasing, you know, earlier in the
week I mentioned when you look at some states
that have been open versus closed, you see
very similar curves.
And we speculated this could be because an
open state might have a lot of people isolating
on their own, whereas a closed state might
have a lot of people ignoring the protocol.
It could be that states are falsifying data.
We don't really know.
In terms of the numbers that Florida has released
the case, numbers have been declining pretty
modestly, sort of a similar pattern to states
that have been mostly shut down.
Maybe a question mark in light of this recent
revelation in terms of the deaths.
There is a strange sort of herky jerky up
and down graph for Florida deaths.
Sometimes when you see that it has to do with
reporting intervals where certain days of
the week you don't get full data and numbers
are pushed around potentially.
You know, often it's weekends, the numbers
go down.
And it's not because fewer people are dying
on the weekend.
It's because the reporting is pushed to Monday
and Tuesday and tallied early in the following
week.
We're not really sure in terms of testing
levels.
Florida is testing about 33000 per million.
That puts them at twenty seventh in the United
States.
That's right.
About the middle.
Florida is not particularly good or bad on
testing.
But again, this is what they are releasing.
And that's all we really know.
We may know more soon, as I say, but we may
not.
And that's the whole point that.
This is a story about the fact that we are
not being given information that is absolutely
necessary to figure out what's going on in
Florida to determine are they ready to move
to a phase one or phase two reopening or whatever
the case may be.
Once again, it's projection that the right
has been saying that the left is falsifying
data for a while now.
No actual evidence of that, but now increasingly
evidence that it is the right that may be
indeed doing that.
And the very right wing Florida state government
of Governor Ron DeSantis is at the at the
center of this at this point in time.